Removing People From History (Damnatio Memoriae)
Damnatio memoriae (condemnation of memory)
was a punishment reserved for certain people
the Romans decided to dishonour for one reason
or another.
Rather impressively, it involved trying to
get rid of all records that the person ever
existed.
Understandably, historians aren’t aware
of any people to whom this dishonor was successfully
applied, since if they did, it wouldn’t
have been successful.
They are, however, aware of a number of high
profile cases in which damnatio memoriae was
decreed, but we still know of the individuals
today.
Before we get ahead of ourselves, we should
discuss what the specifics are behind damnatio
memoriae itself and what one would need to
do to earn such a punishment.
Damnatio memoriae was normally reserved for
those such as Senators and Emperors whose
acts did not reflect well on Rome, or those
who committed treason or a number of other
serious crimes.
Brutal or tyrannical emperors were particularly
susceptible to earning a date with the giant
eraser of history.
The methods used to rid the world of any record
of the individual in question included striking
the individual’s name from all official
records; seizing their possessions; and anything
bearing their likeness or name (statues, murals,
writings, etc.) would be destroyed or otherwise
defaced.
To really rub it in, if the person being stricken
from memory just so happened to be dead at
the time, which was common, their will would
be annulled and their grave defaced.
That said, fully removing some of these high
profile people, such as Emperors, from history
proved to be exceptionally difficult, and
despite the Roman’s best efforts, at least
some of the people who suffered damnatio memoriae
as a punishment are still in the history books.
For example, consider Roman Emperor Maxentius
who, despite being a victim of damnatio memoriae
in 312AD at the hands of Emperor Constantine,
we still know a lot about.
Maxentius’ father, Maximian, was also subjected
to damnatio memoriae in 310AD by Emperor Constantine.
However, Constantine changed his mind and
Maximian was instead deified, essentially
making him a God in the eyes of the Roman
people.
Which we’re sure he would have enjoyed more
if Constantine hadn’t forced him to commit
suicide in 310AD.
A Roman Emperor that was, rather surprisingly,
saved from this fate was the famously mad,
Emperor Caligula.
When Caligula was assassinated in 41 AD, his
successor, Claudius immediately shot down
the Senate’s attempts at removing his nephew’s
memory from history.
This is a particularly notable case in that
it is known that the decision to try to remove
Caligula from history was heavily influenced
by public opinion, suggesting that popular
opinion played a part in deciding who to punish
via damnatio memoriae.
Perhaps one of the more dark instances of
damnatio memoriae is the story of Publius
Septimius Geta who was murdered in his mother’s
arms on his older brother, Caracalla’s,
orders.
After the murder of his brother, Caracalla
declared damnatio memoriae on his brother’s
name and had 20,000 people he didn’t like
executed while he was at it.
By all accounts, Caracalla’s order was incredibly
thorough and few images of Geta survived.
However, there was one thing Caracalla couldn’t
get rid of completely, the millions of coins
sporting his brother’s face circulating
freely throughout his empire.
Also, due to Geta’s popularity with the
people of Rome, Caracalla was forced to give
his brother a lavish funeral.
Damnatio memoriae is still practiced on occasion
by various people and groups in one form or
another.
For instance Stalin was famous for erasing
people he didn’t like from photos and official
documents, such as the picture included in
the show notes.
The disappearing man is Nikolai Yezkov, one
time very powerful head of the NKVD (People’s
Commissariat for Internal Affairs).
In his post there, he presided over numerous
tortures and mass-executions during the Great
Purge, but later fell out of favor and himself
was tortured until he admitted to being a
traitor; after this, he himself was purged.
Once this happened, he became “The Vanishing
Commisar” with records of him, including
in photographs, suddenly disappearing, which
was no small feat given the high profile position
Yezkov had previously held.